we fell into this trap that said we were
going to export Big Macs and happy meals
and western music was a big part of this
too to places like China to spread
democracy that was our vision of
democratic capitalism in the 1990s
bipartisan consensus by the way
Republicans and Democrats alike
what they realized is oh wait a minute
we can use these vehicles as a way to
actually spread our values back to them
we they thought they could use our money
to get them to be more like us China
says okay we're going to use access to
our Market to get America to be more
like us how did that work
what they basically said is you can't
enter the Chinese market be it a music
company a movie company Etc a lot of
entertainment fits this description you
can't enter Disney fits this description
the NBA fits this description you can't
enter the Chinese market
unless and until
you abide by the ccp's way of doing
things